at extreme weather continues to grip a
good part of the nation this morning
leaving behind a path of destruction
a woman was killed Friday north of
Cleveland Ohio when the tree apparently
uprooted during the storm toppled and
crushed her car authorities were able to
rescue her baby who was buckled in the
backseat also on Friday in Utah three
sisters ages 2 7 and 8 were struck by
lightning near a lake about 70 miles
east of Salt Lake City all three were
hospitalized two are in critical
condition an intensive search is
underway for at least one person who was
swept away in fast-moving floodwaters
near Las Vegas rescue crews pulled six
people to safety across the West this is
turning out to be a summer of unusual
and dangerous weather
here's Carter Evans strong summer storms
hit the Phoenix area Friday triggering
rivers of mud this group narrowly
escaped the floodwaters as their
belongings got swept away elsewhere in
Phoenix high winds toppled trees and
part of the zoo was damaged forcing it
to close on Friday but no animals were
injured this is actually a road in
California the town of Acton north of
Los Angeles was pummeled by a powerful
thunderstorm Thursday
flash flooding trapped motorists in cars
this man had to be airlifted to safety
very serious situation out here the
storm also brought a torrent of hail it
just felt like someone's like throwing
rocks at your windows I mean it was just
so intense I had never ever seen
anything like that in my life
the flooding stopped a commuter train
literally in its tracks as the storm
caused the ground to erode nearly 200
passengers evacuated in the high desert
you can see where floodwaters came right
up to the front steps of this home at
its peak it was about three feet deep
right here turning the road out front
into a rushing river on Friday the water
receded but left behind a muddy mess we
just moved in here probably eight months
ago we just lost everything
in the Pacific Northwest Portland has
endured one of its most prolonged heat
waves in years hardware stores sold out
of air conditioners and health officials
warned about the dangers from excessive
heat the biggest concern is heatstroke
where the body gets really hot the
sweating mechanism shuts down and that's
potentially life-threatening five days
of temperatures over 90 degrees head zoo
officials busy keeping animals cool
she loves the big wave for CBS this
morning Saturday Carter Evans Los
Angeles